[Musique]
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait pour avoir
autant de chance attends c'est moi que
tu parles autant vouloir
[Musique]
j'aimerais pouvoir le crier à tout le
monde
il va falloir qu'on le dise assez
rapidement bonjour
tu crois que c'est le bon moment pour
dire qu'on en fera le règlement
[Musique]
toi tu me passes le dire au téléphone
on va boire un verre tu veux venir
on vous doit la moitié des gros coups du
dernier trimestre
[Applaudissements]
alors il voulait quoi c'est moi la
nouvelle pierre
félicitations je suis désolé pourquoi je
suis trop content pour toi
on se demande pas comment elle a obtenu
le poste la voir comme boss sérieux mais
[Musique]
jette un coup d'oeil et donne-moi ton
avis
[Musique]
un autre maintenant que tu gagnes plus
que moi
qu'est-ce que tu fais
c'est juste un jeu auquel tu es très
doué
tu vas le pitcher oui ou non je crois
pas que ce soit une bonne idée on peut
pas bosser la tous les deux je m'en irai
pas cette entreprise et devenu ma
religion et vous vous êtes devenus mon
Dieu si vous me donnez cette opportunité
je vous donnerai tout ce que j'ai
complètement péter les plombs c'est
vraiment comme ça tu vas mettre fin à
notre relation en lâchant une [__] de
bon
on fait tous des trucs sales mais la
merde on la ramène pas au bureau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]